so excited to have you on the show uh I
uh I have to say it is uh for my money
Breaking Bad uh I'm a TV buff I've love
TV on my life I think it's one of the
best shows it's ever been on television
and it's absolutely ring thank you and I
you probably had the
exper do you have something to say
Andy Sopranos was pretty good
too and heha that's true you know I
first episode loved it I love the first
episode was fantastic I know that you
made that just for me magnets
yeah yeah well it's one of those shows
too where you have to watch it right
away or you're going to run into people
who start to quote lines and ruin things
so I sequester myself watch the episode
and then I release myself into the wild
yeah it's kind of like if someone uh
tells you the score of a of a big
important game it just ruins everything
for you yeah no you can't do that you
got to you got to watch those shows
quickly before you talk to anybody this
show has pervaded the culture to such a
degree that there is now a Lego meth lab
set no there's not yes there is we have
photographs of it this is the Lego math
lab set which is fantastic this is this
is actually very good to see because um
science has been lacking in our country
yeah there they are look at look these
uniforms love you guys look at poor
worri Jesse poor wor Jesse Jess always
worried yeah confident wolt putting
putting things together very hard to
make meth like this with pinchers it can
be done it's good for the beakers and
bad for that's true yeah yeah you just
yeah I worry so it's going to it's going
to it's going to get out there uh I
mentioned this you've had three is this
correct three consecutive Emmys yes I I
do you seem ashamed to have it
mentioned
now John Ham of Mad Men Fame terrific
actor has said he's gone on record he
says he will kick your ass if you win
again that's what John Ham says are you
do you fear for your life now you know
what he said that like after my second
one and um he did you know I I and he
won a third and then I won a third and
what did he do nothing he did nothing I
well to tell you your ass remains
unkicked Ked I know I have uh more
resistance to ham than a hidic Jew so
I'm I'm good
it worked better with you than I enjoyed
it I enjoyed it uh Walter White your
character has uh has famously gone from
this very seemingly mild-mannered Meek
person to being completely ruthless and
scary uh can you be that tough and
intimidating in real
life what kind of question is
that
[Applause]
huh funny boy
okay funny boy all I can think is he
thinks I'm
funny okay I'm ready to die that's how
needy I am he kicked my ass but he
thought he was
funny uh you
know is is there any you tap you must be
tapping into something there must be
some part of you that's a badass you
know what's what this has taught me
playing Walter White is that anyone
given the right set of circumstances I
mean you and you MH you guys could both
become
dangerous given the right set of
circumstance if I press the right
buttons look
out I'm right Ian yes you are right yeah
well I think no one surprised that this
guy when I even the way you say fact
that I did
that
I'm a pretty tough
character now you put no one who makes
little butterflies with their hands I'm
a pretty rough
God you don't want to mess with this guy
you're talking to me
yeah he's a a burning cauldron of
childish rage what people don't know
about Andy is he's incredibly strong
he's got he's got Incredible strength I
know this is not a joke or anything Andy
is a very powerful man he is when he
hugs you you feel it yeah really do and
when he spoons with you look out it
could be very dangerous that's right
when he nuzzles your neck you know it
you know he's there when you cuddle
anyway we could go on and on and on